day drinking that's what I like the most
[Music]
how did Elizabeth Banks do is our et
correspondent for you the other day she
killed it I couldn't not be sincere with
her she was like I thought you were
gonna joke around when I asked you how
it was to work with me and I was like
you asked girl and I got real with you
just as I would a real et correspondent
and we get real for a minute
yes the other Dan Howard Stern you
beautifully spoke about Dylan you're
gonna propose how do you know she's the
one how do you know that you know when
you know you know I don't know what else
to say
an angel in your life yes
[Music]
the drag race angels were on the carpet
tonight earlier the ones that you shot
that video with have you ever thought
about what your drag name would be we're
asking everyone oh gosh oh man if I had
a drag name there'd be something really
bro e and like Valley like something
like something like oh man like
something like doping well you're like
yo like something pop punky like like my
brother's name is Cameron maybe like
Blake do you don't even you know like
over it yeah like in like a valley bro
name put it in a generator and actually
what you got is Dame ivana bang bang oh
wow that's very elegant and sort of like
fancy for me I think I might new like
Jane
[Music]
[Applause]
let's talk about what you're wearing
this fashion look ready for this
it's a Sherman yang I love this dress
okay Sherman yay what do you love about
well I finally were doing the Charlie's
Angels premiere tonight it wasn't like
that serious
I wanted to be like if a cupcake had a
topper be this guy yeah movie is so much
about female empowerment and serves a
lot of looks have to ask you did you
take anything from that closet just as a
little memento no I did it because we
want to make a sequel so late it yeah
but keep the jockey outfit keep the
writing boots
maybe we'll be back to put them on again
something
[Music]